So who's a DREAMer?
Us two.
You two.
Because you're undocumented?
Right.
How old were you when you came?
Five.
Did you tell your mom, "Hey,
Mom, I want to go to the US
and I'm going to go
without you." No?
We didn't have a choice.
You didn't have a choice?
No.
No?
I didn't find out
I was undocumented
until I wanted to enlist
in the military and I couldn't.
And the option that the
recruiter gave me was like,
"Well, you can marry me,"
because some people want to
take advantage of the situation.
But I don't want to do that.
I don't want to marry
because of that.
And it's like,
is that my only option?
And I know that it's reality
to a lot of women like me
because we, in a way,
we don't have a voice
because we don't have
a security number.
We can't vote.
We can't do a lot of things.
She wants to go to college.
She wants to help out
the American economy,
the American community.
She's an American.
She wasn't born on this side
of the river,
but she's an American.
Ross: Our president has dropped
any protections
that keep these kids
from being deported.
But where would they go?
They've never lived
anywhere else.
Even some of his supporters
think that's [Bleep].
They've got a right to be here.
They do?
It wasn't their choice
to come to the U.S.
Yeah.
They didn't break the law.
It was their parents' choice...
Their parents broke the law.
...that brought them here.
As far as I'm concerned,
they're part of our society.